this is a Fox News Alert just in the
past few minutes the FBI has released a
statement saying they've arrested five
residents of that compound in New Mexico
we've been telling you about on a
federal criminal complaint charging them
with violating the Federal Firearms and
conspiracy laws now this is the same
compound where officials found several
children living in terrible conditions a
short time ago they also found one child
dead earlier this week you may remember
a judge dismissed many charges against
five compound residents in custody we're
following this breaking story again out
of New Mexico they've been arrested five
of them according to the FBI